[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
[Applause] [
[Applause]
good evening good evening yesterday we were at the
40lone museum he's not going to the campsite
and you talked a bit about the
African farm what is it  who did you like about
this book, she
's the king she's going to, she tries to
say exactly what she experienced, what she
felt, and she has a completely
direct way, moreover, the
first sentence of  the African farm
is clear, it's bright and we
obviously want to follow it right away,
now I
feel I feel something
you know is a bit close to
her because she  a she
really experienced I mean great great
suffering
but at the same time great she always
tried precisely to
react and I think that I always have a
kind of sorority with women
writers or artists for whom it doesn't
was not easy
[Music]
10 has just quoted
the Swedish Academy the Nobel committee
saluting you for your courage
on Saturday it's an academy
so courage and criticism and this
courage I would like to ask you, Madame
Arnaud
to  where does this courage come from then I'm going to
disappoint you I think
it's not the impression of having
courage simply I I tried to
face as best as possible all
kinds of things that are not
specific to me who goes through
lives and to give a resolution
in life already but also that is not
enough and let's say that each time
something is asked of me to write
to write that's it and in fact it's
because this  that I live
does not seem enough to me
here life is not
enough for me was not enough for me here
[Music]
the young man registered
if I do not write them things
did not go to their end they
were  only lived but what is
full practs
can you talk a little more about it
yes
for example
the young man it is indeed the
last text that I wrote and which is
very brief but it is  that I had
started it more than 20 years ago so
an affair with a man a young man
who is
25 years old 26 years younger than me and how
this what is
made a story that
perhaps happens a little less often between  an
older woman and a younger man
but all the same and one thing that happens
and what me everything that I experienced
during this of this relationship
in fact I had only taken notes and that's
it  I absolutely needed to
format to tell the story
what there had been in this story of
individuals in fact that's it
the young man there is too much to start
[Music]
and moreover in shame  that I have here
therefore the shame you write I have always
wanted to write books which it
is then impossible for me to talk about
which make the gaze of others
unbearable
yes
[Applause]
exact at the time I write it
c  that is to say 20
years ago already a little over 20 years ago I would say that
maybe now
20 years 25 years later
it is no longer the same desire that I have to
write  books that make the
gaze of others unbearable quite
simply because since that time
I believe that
writing has taken up so much space
in my life
that the gaze of others can no longer be so much
I loved myself so here we go
the time you still have three fires you
work etc because there was
all that I was I was 25 years of me
I believe that indeed
and that with time and it is
certainly not specific to  me with the
advancing years and well we have a
greater form of a difference to the
judgment of others I believe yes
fortunately
[Music]
but do you remember
this desire absolutely
[Music]
it was a  observation because in fact
when I write the shame I have a project
of books still which are very
difficult to write there is the event
on this clandestine abortion and there is
this book which is not yet translated
here but  which is memory of girls
on on a my first sexual relationship
so there is here I still have a project
at this time a lot of books which
precisely ask for very certainly
at this time to face to face
the look therefore fencing
[Music  ]
I would like to add something is
that indeed there is therefore there is this
desire and this yes indeed a sort
of fear of the gaze of others
or their 1 when I write
everything disappears I absolutely no longer experience
any  I'm going to the
end I'm going to the end so I'm
absolutely no longer afraid and
when I've finished when I've
finished then
at that moment there is this passage this
passage from  text that no one has
read yet because no one I don't give anyone
a bed my books this text
is who will become who will pass who
will become public who will who will be I
don't know what it becomes but it
becomes a public thing and this passage
there is and it's a moment it's
indeed here and but once
it's done and well it's over I
mean and I in a certain way I
risk my  fear
of my fear because in fact
people don't care at all here
and what counts is the book here
then on the other hand there are there are
readers who often say yes to me but
it doesn't matter to you  in relation to your
family in relation to that here is to do
that and indeed as it is done I
say no
here then most certainly if I will
speak about it before
my family would indeed
perhaps have some fear but
I do not speak about it  no that
's it no
[Music]
but I think I don't know if it's
in the movie the Super 8 years but
I've read or seen you say that
if we're talking about your family for example
I think  that your husband was not very
happy with the book the frozen woman for
example
[Laughs]
yes of course then there are many
things why I am writing this book it was
certainly and it is one thing that is that to me
it appeared next I
wrote this book actually to
analyze to dive back to the bottom how did
I become this woman this woman
so was at 35 to 35 years old and to find the
way etc but there was most
certainly another
another motivation  and who
was in fact certainly to find my
freedom thanks to this text that is to say
that I perhaps was not able to
make a decision myself and that
I asked the book that I was writing to
take  this decision
that's it I see it very very well
now years ago of
course that's it
[Music]
you say in the film that you were
a young woman tormented by the desire
to  'write yes because the film that
was screened
here is these are the extremely
important years in my life they are
years when I start writing it again here
and as it is very
I do not want to talk about it to anyone I
don't want to talk to anyone about it
because what I wanted to write is very
different from what I wanted to write
before saying what I want to write
touches very very deeply on my
drums on my life as a woman I'm going to
talk about
an abortion so  my mother is completely unaware of
this abortion there is also
the fact that I am going to tell I am going to
tell this social tear between
the little girl and especially the adolescent
that I was and her uncultivated peasant working class environment
and I know that I  I'm going to
do it in an extremely violent way
so it's a text that can't even be
qualified and so I obviously don't talk about it to
anyone here it is I'm tormented
by it and I'm actually going to write it
in secret I  I'm going to write it
in secret and send it in secret to
publishers it's going to be retained so it's up to it's
a change I mean it's
you could say that writing in my life
arriving like that in  my life and in
this way this way basically
brutal and violent
not at all not at all yes I write
watch I write etc yes I'm going to send
my book no no not at all that's it that's
really and  it's like a
thunderclap and to be published it's
also a thunderclap for me so
it's all that is extremely
violent and I think that
my husband actually took it very badly
[Music]
by  against
in this loser which has just been
published in Danish you write on November 18,
1989 about the death of your mother you say it is
the book about her that saved me
so what power or what  hello little
to have in a book
it's because the death of my mother was
a big
was really a very big shock she
died she had
Alzheimer's disease which in itself is already a
very big ordeal to bear but  i did
n't think she could i did
n't think she could die
suddenly and it's this sudden death of my
mother was
[Music]
havoc somehow yes
finish havoc of
i i had
i  I really had a hard time
coping with living the days and
weeks that followed
his death his death and writing writing
was actually
what saved so when I say
save
it's that actually it's  a term
that I often use the verb to save and
that often
I always think that
writing can save that writing
thinks they are not always but
in this case in this case yes that has me that has me
allowed to write I wanted to
write it was a somewhat crazy wish to write
the most beautiful book there is about a mother
when it was there are certainly
a lot of books on the seas which are
beautiful but to have this desire  there to have
this desire there it was basically the task that
the task that I myself want to propose
to do but it was also for
it was in the name of all women
in a certain way of all
women  who
have known a life that is often difficult
because it is in the past century
and that life has she is a woman a
popular woman she is a woman of the
people my mother and that was it was to
save  also with her other women
maybe we'll follow me
the fastest
man and me
and then I think you write
somewhere that if a book doesn't succeed
in saving the author he can perhaps
save an electric reader
I think that's it, that's it for me,
reading and literature have had this
power to discover things that
alone I wouldn't have discovered so I
it's this function of
literature there are some  other
functions which are to embellish a
moment but
that of
saying to oneself that basically somewhere somewhere the
author the author and me the author is
there is a recognition if that the
recognition
the term recognition it has  meaning in
French
recognition is for example it is to
have learned
here we recognize that you have a
certain here is recognition and then
the word recognition is
effectively to
recognize oneself to recognize oneself in a
text in what a sentence a  page a
book that's it and that's
invaluable it's something and me that's what
I prefer above
all is that
readers can not necessarily recognize themselves
in everything but that at one
given moment and even even that they even forget
that it's my book for here
to bring something
without that we without remembering where we have it where
what saved you basically is that
[Music]
I  would now like to invite the actress
to read us the beginning of the shame
[Music]
and there
[Applause]
you are also describing here a
magical thing the fear the fear of not being
able to write after writing this
scene
[  Music]
of
forbidden so
it's really
in reality of course
after I realize that I
can write that is to say that I have
crossed I have crossed the magic circle
and I believe that it happens for a lot
of  in many cases
that and I would even say that very
certainly there are still a lot of
things that I no doubt forbid myself from writing
and that I must become
aware of that it is indeed
that and
there
I when I  when I agreed
to write at that time I felt that
from there I could actually continue to
write I could constitute
writing
[Music]
and you write
in many of your books  for example
in getting lost
you write the cellar of 1952 my father
wanting to kill my mother it was the crack
in my world
yes
it is moreover on this that I completely
built the book shame because at
from then when in this context
I write this I have not yet at all
the idea of ​​writing this to describe the shame I
am in here in in a passion and
and I write my diary so I don't think about it
not but
when I start writing it's
obviously it's very clear to me
that there is there is childhood and there is
childhood and there is until that moment
there is that moment  there and that moment
it is and well it is I
understand I understand that deep down
my parents are not the
superior beings that I imagined the
beings to myself but that we are at the bottom here
we are part of the neighborhood the
neighborhood with the  so men
who beat their wives
drunken men so my father doesn't drink but there
is this gesture and indeed and I'm
scared like many other children
also from the neighborhood but we do
n't talk because between children  who are
ashamed we don't talk about the things that
make and so there is I keep that and in
relation then in particular in relation to
private school at school so good
little girls who are
wise bourgeois Catholics good I
know I don't  don't belong but I
'm a good student I'm a good student
so it compensates but there it doesn't compensate
it doesn't compensate so that's what I'm saying
it's going into shame
it's like the last words of getting
lost you write  still of
a cellar door that opens yes
exactly
I would also say that in the there is
another scene that is kind of
fulfilled and the
final fulfillment of shame is the scene where with
after a  party
where I come home late with the teacher the
class
and then some students and we knock we
drive all the students back to
their house and we knock on the door of
my mother's store and my mother my mother
goes down goes down in her shirt not  very
clean and hairy and
that's
when I see I see the
teacher and the students looking at
my mother without love
without love and
that's I mean it's the whole
society that's there that's  society who
is who condemns who condemns me who condemns my
mother who and who situates us who
effectively situates us so that's it's
the accomplishment of shame
[Music]
but let's talk a little more about your mother
because your mother is  reader she
says a lot she always has a book in her
hands between two clients she she
the books and we are here in our
national library so we are
surrounded by the books in the
frozen woman you
also talk about a mother the mother of the
narrator who who reads a lot and in
a woman you say that books are
the only objects she handles
with care she even washes her
hands before touching them
how important it was for you to have
a mother 10 years old
is
I think the main thing
is why most certainly I
am I
finally liked I have my books but
very early on
but she encouraged she encouraged
and above all she she preferred it's
really very very clear she preferred
that I read rather than sew that I
knit or do so-called
feminine activities it was very clear
why because for her there was
everything in the books she had a
sacredness
of the books because
not only good she liked to read but
she knew that there were books that
brought a lot she didn't necessarily have them
but she knew that everything through
reading
[Music]
of the transformative power of books
finally the possibility of really changing
things yes I think she saw
d  first
of all saw that reading was
still related to
teaching with teaching but
I must say that for a very long time
things were separated, that is to say there
was homework to do.  school
and there were the books next there were there they were
and she put me in the
finally
she was reading herself she read the the read
a huge book which is
gone with the wind by Margarit Michelle this
big novel and her and me I was 9 years old
and I started to read and I found
it very very interesting I continued
to
and well instead of as some mothers
would have said but no you're too small
and then it's not  for you, here she is, she
contracted, she was exasperated, she found
that, ah, it was still great that
I read a book that was so big, so big
and that didn't just talk about love,
but of course also talked about the
Civil War, even if it was  wasn't on the good
side
of course but here I was so I was in
this it's
something
of A it's so much a part
of my childhood and my youth the
books and so the question is that we
didn't have  no we didn't have a
library at the time we didn't have
a library so there was the
city library which opened
half a day on Sunday morning
that was all so we had to buy books
which  was expensive of course so but
here it is
I think my child it has been a
continuous read
I think we will I read it myself
by the way at the age of 10 11 11 I think
yes c  is really exciting
[Music]
in books so of course there is
still one thing is that my mother
I feel very very well I wanted to
read to Mickey
she asks me what I want I say I
would like to Mickey  and there she says no
no
[Laughs]
finished
[Music]
and we're going to listen to just one page of the
place
[Applause]
we must not take sides for art
he cannot do something
exciting or moving  but but
finding this flat writing
can you describe the path you
have to take to get this new
writing
so it's a winding path
that's been going to take a lot of
time it's the realization that
if I  I didn't write either like in my
previous books
from me finally being the
main subject but that if the main subject
was my father his life then
I had to
ask myself a lot of questions about the
nature
the nature of my language and about  my
position in relation to the subject in
relation to my father and therefore I was
quite simply a woman who had
acquired culture and who wrote
about someone who no longer belonged to
her social class
it was me who did not belong  more to his
social class and he had never
belonged and so there was the question
of
how
I was going to
also express
our bond the bond that we had because
it is not it was precisely I did
I did well  the difference between
writing about someone in my own
family and about someone who would
n't have been from here who would have been a
neighbor who would have been and so it was this
relationship that imposed not
not  make the reader
feel what would have been
absolute horror feels pity or
commiseration commiseration for
the being that
I was talking about that I will have therefore
above all it brought me to say that she
had been her own  culture and his own
culture and that is to say that it is
not funny when I say that he preferred
circus music to any other
so that's if it's so that this position there and
the only way to do it was
to  have this writing that I called
flat but which actually makes a
writing of factual facts a
factual writing
[Music] [
Music]
an arrow
[Music]
you also talk about it in your
Nobel lecture not write well by
write beautiful
it  is true I really wanted to explain
this this position because for me
it is in fact one
that means that
I do not think that writing escapes
[Music]
a political and social vision of
like the rest of the facts of the  society
so it's out of breath it was important for me
to explain
that it's not that it was not in
a way like that from my
inspiration but on the contrary from
a reflection from a reflection to
consider  that writing and
literature are human things and
therefore it relates both to
the history of sociology and
of course to politics
[Music]
I remember a passage in the
very first pages of your first
book
The Empty Lovers where the narrator says
that there is nothing in
literature that can help me and nothing
in literature that can express
what I feel now or that
can describe what  happens
now that's right the
empty cupboards so it's the first book published
and it's in the very first pages
so that's it so it's a novel it's a
moment and so the narrator who
is called by Annie but  Denise Denise
the sure is going through an
abortion so she has pains and
well and she says to herself that there is
actually nothing in the books
she is studying as a college student
and there is nothing  she looks at the books
around her there is nothing that can
express what a girl
who went to an
abortionist and who comes back with a
probe in her stomach what she feels
there and that there is nothing  it's nothing, and I think
that's basically what made me write
this book, but in general
it's writing the books that you think there
are, they weren't written  that's it that's
actually that's what pushes you to
write that's what pushes you to write
rather than believing that you're going to express
your self your
soul etc no that's there isn't there isn't
no so I'm going to write it here it was
indeed that and at that time
it was very very strong for me to write
effectively to write this book in
the 70s or precisely in France
besides the law before was not and
it  it's not yet authorized
Denmark it was in
73 that we had a drunken abortion at
your place it was in 63
[Music] [
Music]
Edward Louis
camp out
'a woman says i
know now they built what they
call literature against
lives and bodies like hers so from
my mother i now know that to write about
her and to write about her life is to write
against the  existing literature
and what effect does it have on you that you have
made marks and echoes like that
in younger generations, for example
with Édouard Louis it's obvious
never to
prove
we think I think we don't think I
mean to others  to those who will
write after themselves but when it happens
as it does it is
obviously to say to themselves that something is
happening and that it's good
it's good because we don't change
everything  only literature perhaps there
must be several also
[Music]
the new observation
[Applause]
the aspiration or the desire that you had
while writing the years
in fact
[Music]
was to go back through
all  the time that I myself had lived
between therefore the arrival at consciousness I
mean four years five years and
until the moment when I will finish the
book here is therefore all this all this
period but not by telling
my life with  the 16 events that is to
say to reverse in fact that is to say
to
introduce
a a woman inside time
that's it that would be me but she would
n't be she wouldn't be
individualized she would be present  with
with the group of women with the group
of people of an era and that's it, that is
to say the opposite of the autobiography
the autobiography it's me in the world
and there it's the world the world  and me
continual that's that this movement there and
so the form obviously took a very
long time to find
once again writing books that
didn't exist
then
my winter
[Music]
and the structure you structured for
example by the meals by the  photos etc
There indeed there is in fact it is
quite structured and indeed there is
the general story with Euro here we are
the general story and there are the moments
which are almost every 10 years
there are the meals  collective meals
with family or friends in 68 it
will be in Ardèche it will be with
people from all
walks of life in a way but so that's
the meal is one and because for
me
getting together is the  one of the
oldest to eat it is certainly one of the
oldest human structure of
certainly and there in these moments when
we have meals
and we talk about the past
we talk about the present and we also talk about
the future how we see it we talk
things we talk we sing we
finally sing and here there was there is
a kind of gift that
moments when there is everything in
life the most important things in
life the meal then the  photos that
allowed me to introduce then there
this woman to introduce her it's the
little girl and it will happen to the
grandmother with her little girl her
description of at the same time the
description what
she thinks about what she thinks about  what she
thinks about the present also what she
remembers and what she how she
imagines the future yes we always have these
three moments of time in everything in the
structure of the book and that's the
two big ones it's good  in fact the
two main structures plus the
general story here
we cannot do
[Music]
there is a great melancholy melancholy
I find there is of course the
passage of time we are getting older our children
are getting older everything changes he leaves us
all that but he  there is also I think that was
why all this fight everything
that we did that leads to what
consumption liberalism
hypermarket so
let's say that
in the current state yes of course that's it
but we don't know the rest
I'm  am stopped so indeed there
is already the direction we have not
changed much but there are still
new things all the same the
taking into account precisely of the
destruction of the planet it is
something of which we who existed  anyway
I talk about it too but but at that
time we don't learn it into account as
we do now for example well there
is change also in I
mean the place of women in the
world
is still I  think
now
I have in question insofar as it
has always been dominated so there are
therefore there are still changes but
it will be others to write the sequel that
optimism
[Music]
we were talking about at the beginning of  the basement and
the unbearable and all that but when we
say getting lost for example there is
also a great desire a pleasure to
write to write I make love with
this same desire for perfection as in
writing and I don't  I've never wanted
love and literature so there's
also something very beautiful, very
amorous, very sensual in writing
yes in fact it goes beyond all the same I
think it goes beyond sensuality
I think I'm yes indeed
i think it's this style of
dimensions
and i would like to ask you at the end to
just read us the last page
of the years
the years begin one can't
i'm just going to say what happens at the
beginning where the first sentence it  is she
nobody wants
all the images will disappear
save things
save the little ball in
bazoches-sur-rhône with the
bumper cars the hotel room rue
Beauvoisine in Rouen not far from the
Le Pouzet bookstore where kayak had
shot a scene of dying of  love
the wine drawer at the intersection of rue
du Parmelan Annecy
I leaned on the beauty of the world
and I held the smell of the seasons in
my hands
the merry-go-round I left badly from hundreds
of stockings
the very young woman  in a red coat
who accompanied the man staggering on the
sidewalk she had gone to look for at the
café Le Dieu Guesclin in winter at La
Roche Posay
the film of people of no importance the
half-torn poster 36 15
ula at the bottom of the côte de
fleury-  sur-andelle a bar and a jukebox
that played Apache atelier at the corner
a house at the end of a garden 35 avenue
Edmond Rostand in Villiers-le-Bel
the gaze of the black and white cat
when falling asleep under the  pricked
the man in pajamas and slippers every
afternoon in the hall of the
retirement home in Pontoise who cried while
asking visitors to call his
son, holding out a piece of dirty paper on
which was written the number of
the wife of  the photo of the massacre of
Hocine Algeria which looked like a
pietà
the sun blousing on the walls of
San Mickey the from the shadow of the depths
where we will never again be
[Applause]
thank you too